hello everyone we are back to the
Capablanca saga which means we are back
at the Sabourin carbine sucked Victor
Borge its 1913 and it's the second game
ever kappa blanka played against
Alexander alien like we mentioned in the
previous video in this saga acaba Blanca
was invited in son Peter works to face a
face off against three very strong
Russian masters Alexander alien is
Moscow borovsky induced Joe to me risky
and already we've seen one game against
an Asian couple on had the white pieces
and it was a very convincing victory but
now let's see how capablanca fares
against young red even wear a lien has
the white pieces so without further ado
let's check out the game and also let's
check out this very nice photo of the
two of them we were able to find out
that it actually is a photo from the
previous game that we've shown so let's
just enjoy it for a few seconds just to
get in the mood so now really without
further ado I and opens with E for we
have E 5 Knight to f3 we have nice to us
c6 sorry about that and the Bishop to b5
the reuleaux PES is on the board a 6
more fees defense Bishop to a 4
we have Knight to f6 and now castles and
here a couple of long could go into the
line where you capture d4 pawn but he
didn't consider it to be all that all
that great it would seem Bishop c5
Bishop captures pawn captures and then
d4 seems just like a like a nice
position for whites to play but it is
played even today so it's not really a
problem Capablanca here is simply
continues developing we have Bishop to
e7
rook to e1 and now b5 we have Bishop to
b3 and here Capablanca goes for d6
but I will also mention this as a fun
fact here a cup of lanka could go for
castles and after c3 go d5 this is the
marshal attack as you all know those of
you who have been following my channel
for quite some time now we have shown
the game where Frank James Marshall
prepared this for the first time ever
against none other than josé raúl
capablanca but Capablanca could not play
it here in 1913 because it was not until
1918 that Frank James Marshall played
this move against Foster
kappa blanka so for those of you that
are interested in that game is well
aware marshal for the first time ever
employed the marshal's gambit against
Capablanca it will be the first link you
will see in the description below a
legendary game it would be a shame if
you missed out on it so every Bishop to
b3 d6 capablanca cannot go for the four
heard the marshal attack as it was not
yet invented C 3 we have 925 pressuring
the bishop bishop c2 and now c 5 the
knight was moved now you can grab more
space here with black we have d4 and now
Queen to c7 and this position has been
played so many times over over the
course of years that is it is considered
standard theory of the rule opus even
today as they were this was played in
1913 but a hundred years from this game
in 2013 even charge had this exact same
position against the ever gaining post
knee and he defeated him with a for such
a line but it all it's also the move
that a lien used in this game against
kappa blanka so it's really amazing that
you know a line that stood the test of
time for 400 years we have before and
now Knight beat to be 2 we have castles
by capablanca and now comes the night to
f1 a pretty standard maneuver would the
night depending on what black plays this
night will either come to e3 or g3 and
now this position has been reached
several times throughout the course of
history but no one ever played the seek
after Sun d4 move couple Blanc I used in
this game against Talia him and ok seek
after Sun d4 and now Bishop to e6 a
couple of long has ideas of plane b3
here and we have Knights to e3 you could
try something like d5 but you do block
the bishop but after this a couple
longer could go rook F c8 attack your
undefended bishop on see to its defended
but only once and after the bishop moves
now you can go Bishop to g4 and black
really gets a nice grip on the C file so
after Bishop to e6 first we have night
to e3
now defending the bishop here and now we
have rook a to ca
with Bishop to d2 pressuring the the b4
pawn and now comes Knight to c4
now what's Kappa Blancas idea would
Knight to c4 he's attacking the defender
of the c2 bishop
so if alien were to grab this pawn here
now simply Knight captures wins the game
as the bishop is no longer guarded pawn
captures Queen captures here and black
wins apiece
so after Knight to c4 we have Knight
captures on c4 Queen captures on c4 and
now here the best way to approach this
as your Bishop is now definitely an
attack is to simply move it but alien
starts complicating things the rook is
much needed on the a file to protect the
e4 pawn as b3 is coming at a at a
certain moment that the bishop and queen
have prepared that but idea he instead
goes look to c1 and okay couple Blanca
please
b3 he says okay I will grab your a4 pawn
and I will give up my central pawn will
rush up to be one attacking a couple
Blancas Queen Queen captures an a4 and
now D captures on e on e5 d captures and
Knight captures and here kappa blanka
says okay you grab my central poem but
now if you look at the Queen side I have
a two-to-one advantage considering pawn
so if all the pieces come off the board
it will really mean a lot in the endgame
we have rook captures on c1 Bishop
captures on c1 and now Luke comes to d8
with an attack on the Queen Queen to e2
and now comes h6 both capablanca and I
can now make some room for their Kings
to avoid any background weaknesses and
the knight and Queen are pressuring d4
pawn you can play something like f3 it
would weaken your king too much and also
you would lose your knight here to this
check
so after h6 we have h3 and now comes
Bishop to c5 now Capablanca as I - has a
very strong Bishop has a very strong
Bishop here here eyeing a couple uncas
King Capablanca now also is preparing to
create a very strong bishop pair here
with bush up to f4 and now comes Knight
to d7 and here instead of trading
immediately first rook to d1 by awaken
as Capablanca rook and e8 is unprotected
we have Bishop to b6 now the bishop is
protecting the rook and now Knight back
to f3 I didn't even
we have Bush up the c4 attacking aliens
Queen the Queen now has to move Queen e1
and now comes Knight to c5 offering a
trade of rooks and here most likely rook
captures Bishop captures and now Bishop
e3 is is the best course of action for
white but a giant again decides to
complicate things he goes Bishop to d6
he wants to play e5 and create this very
nice out was for his Bishop and
capablanca should most likely meet this
with Bishop to b5 just opening up his
Queen here and after E 5 now creating
this very nice outpost Knights to e6 and
yes you do block a couple monocles rook
now but this barrier is mostly blocking
white not black for example after a lien
continues let's say Queenie 4 you could
trade Queens here Queen captures Bishop
captures but now comes rook to c8 and
there are even possibilities of
something like rook to c2 as with the
bishop air cover Blanca will not mind
giving up the exchange here to promote
this pawn to come to c2 already so here
this would have been a possibility and
most likely after this Bishop to d6 move
capablanca would play this but he found
a different plan
perhaps this complicating matters rubbed
off on him and he decided to complicate
matters as well he played the Knights to
d3 attacking the Queen and also what do
you do here - finds a very nice
reputation he plays a person d3 and now
comes a rook captures on d6 okay it's a
nice in-between move but here eilean
doesn't doesn't play the absolute best
move here i Lincoln goes rook to a-1
first attacking a couple Blancas Queen
on a4 but there is one move it seems
that both of them missed so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
idea both of them or seemingly missed in
this position now I'll give you a couple
of seconds for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent pawn snatcher and for those of
you who just won't enjoy the show Bishop
captures on c4 is the idea now if Queen
captures the rook will capture the rook
on d6 so first you have to grab the roof
and
but now first you grab the pawn on f7
Bishop captures on f7 check you don't
allow the Queen to capture the bishop
just in c4 for free
King captures and only now Queen
captures on d1 and now if you count the
pawns here it seems election is up upon
five to four okay
still you could argue papa Blanca has a
bishop against tonight and has still
this to two to one point advantage on
the Queen side but I don't think two of
them agreed that this would be better
for black in any way so it seems that
both of them missed this idea which is
quite quite awesome
I mean it's couple Blanca playing
galleon not likely for either of them to
miss something like this so it might be
that that they agreed that this would be
wouldn't this position would not be
better for white even though white is up
upon but you know it's hard to say at
this moment now but okay rook to d6 we
have looked to a1 by the again attacking
copper Blancas Queen now comes Queen to
b5 with a triple attack against the
bishop here
Bishop captures Queen captures and here
again now in somewhat inferior position
could still continue playing this with
something like e five but again it's a
difficult position but here I a hint
plate look back the c1 he attacked a cup
of Blancas Queen but now you are free to
pause the video here and try to find the
winning idea for Capablanca which are
you can unfortunately for him missed
again I'll give you a couple of seconds
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
player and for those who just want to
enjoy it show I think most likely
thought that cup of Blanco would have to
move the Queen and then I yeah and we'll
just improve the position of his own
queen but here kappa blanka just played
Queen to c2 and now it's okay now it
becomes obvious that the Queen cannot be
captured but it's not so simple why the
Queen cannot be captured because if if
rook captures pawn captures yes now
you're threatening rook to d1 and the
game is over
but after night the d2 blocking both
rook d1 and the the pawn can still not
be promoted
black has a Bishop to a5 and now after
Queen to c1 rook captures on d2 you have
to
take your passed pawn and see to the
bishop now protects the rook on D - and
now comes King to H - you don't want a
lot of room do you want to come with the
check now for the time being Rudy one is
not possible because of Queen captures
on c2 but again you get better up to c7
checked and now doesn't really matter
what do you play you can't you don't
have any pawns to block it with you
would have to block it or or go back
with a king then lose the rogue d1 but
now rope captures on F to check King to
g1 and now push her back to b6
threatening some discoveries and after
the King moves yet again now comes Luke
to e2 and now again you don't really
have much options here either
Bishop to have - followed by rook to e1
wins as you will prepare grabbing of the
Queen that way or let's say queen f1
then comes rogue d2 and again there's no
defense against rook to d1 either
winning the Queen or rogue d1 and then
black will get another Queen into the
game so yeah after Queen to c2 other
things started looking you know bleak
for for her Alexandra he played King to
h2 but it's not much better now Queen
captures unbe - just eliminating the
spawn and creating a very strong passed
pawn on b3
I didn't play e5 with Bishop captures on
F - now just attacking couple of other
hints Queen Queen to f1 and now rook to
g6 now the rook and Queen will
constantly be pressuring this g2 pawn we
have looked to see a check King to h7
and now comes look to f8 trying to
create create a passed pawn of his own
but you know it's a much too late for
such things Queen to c2 making room for
a couple Blancas passed pawn rook
captures on f7 and not be too here we
have looked the b7 controlling the b1
square would the rook and also with the
Queen but now simply Bishop to b6
cutting off the rooks the defense of the
b1 square as the rook from g6 protects
the bishop on b6 we have 932
now Knight also guards the square but
there's no point capablanca simply
captures it we have e 6 bialyan and now
comes be one with the Queen capablanca
brings another Queen into the game and
it was in this position
I'll move 42 that Alexander Lee again
resigned the game
what if you resign after queen capture
squink after series checkmate and if you
don't capture then Capablanca has two
queens and that's reason in itself
enough to resign the game but yeah both
the games are very nice like we said in
a game one World Cup along had the white
pieces are very convincing win if you
haven't seen it you know do check it out
and in this game - really it's it's
amazing that the line used is still
being used 100 years from this game but
yeah couple I didn't had a better
position in in in a lot of a lot of
moves and he definitely had chances but
in moments where he should have just you
know kept it simple and just continue
playing the game he started complicating
matters and then one cup of Lanka simply
had no other choice he decided to
complicate as well and this is the end
result kappa blanka has two Queens on
the board but yeah definitely an
interesting him and I decided that I
will only tell you the results of this
Cup after the second game against
Alexander akin so coupled Monaco won two
games against Alexander Ali and he won
both games against duty mere skis so he
won both matches but against Tosca
Borowski
he won one game and lost one game so
that match was a tie and then the cup
was awarded to Oscar Borowski as
Capablanca failed to win on on all terms
are yeah I know what you're gonna say
seems unfair it's five to one in favor
of Capablanca but those were the terms
Capablanca was just considered that much
stronger than everyone else in those
days and this was just you know a nice
test for the for the Russian masters so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and that you are enjoying the
Capablanca saga so far so next time you
are you know in a bar or library with
your friends you can always tell them
that the first time hosts a row kappa
blanka met with Alexandrian he has
defeated again into 2-0 but you know in
the second game where I even had the
white pieces it was it was a really
close call
so I would like to thank Joel more a
glucose chunk of Alfred Robison Lauren
Benedict and the Jack French for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon with some of your own
suggestions but all
so continuing the Capobianco saga we are
going into the 1914 tournament of some
Peterburg where we are also going to be
joined by a world champion Emanuel
Lasker thank you all and I will see you
soon